a rooster cat and Ronald orders in
number three it's episode 41 of IMG city
life oh hi and here's a necktie that's
formal and manly though of course I
prefer one-piece cat faces too much
coverage we'll try on one of these or
just wear a slice of bread on your face
it's almost as good as squishing it up
against bars
Hayashi Natsume takes photos of herself
relaxing mid-jump
[Music]
Tugg on a blowhole with this whale
tissue holder and the movie poster for
the Dark Knight Rises contains an
awesome hidden bat shape but some people
see a jumping unicorn here kid have a
sparkler that I mean say cheese dough
the babies okay so take your dog for a
walk
skate and then put a price sticker on
moby-dick just right and you get whoa
okay look let's just get some knowledge
in Canada postal codes are alphanumeric
and in British Columbia you can visit
feed for G one in four all right let's
be more mature every year during the wet
season Lake Titicaca overflows into lake
poop Oh which in turn overflows into
salar de uyuni the world's largest salt
bed it is so big it contains 70% of our
world's lithium reserves and it's so
flat that orbiting satellites use it to
determine the steadiness of their
altitudes when it rains salar de uyuni
becomes the world's largest mirror but
if that's too much water for you you
don't have to travel very far to get to
the an affogato region of the atacama
desert the driest place on earth
on average the entire desert only
receives one millimeter of rain each
year and some weather stations out there
have yet in human history to have
recorded rainfall in fact between 1570
and 1971 it is estimated that no
significant water fell there at all it's
so near sterile nASA uses the region to
test Mars rovers and in some areas of
the desert those Rovers found not a
single trace of life on facebook.com /
Vsauce gaming panayotis showed that with
the right clouds the Sun can become a
smiley face he also showed off an
inquisitive beard and Tim Ryan helped
out okay don't go left and then I'll go
wait I'm just gonna lay around with some
chicks and as always thanks for watching
you